- She started using the
printing out transcripts of Khan Academy
and giving him these sheets,
these stacks of paper when
she visited him in prison.
and through just the transcripts
Jason was able to start realizing that he,
you know in school he felt weak in math
but now he's like I can learn this stuff
and his sentence was was taken down
from 30 years to still 15 years
so now in his mid-30s
he's released from prison
he's feeling more confident
about his knowledge.
He goes to community college
and then he's able to
use Khan Academy properly
with the videos and the exercises
what a lot of y'all are familiar with
and then he decides
he wants to transfer
to a four-year college.
He uses the SAT prep
that we do in partnership
with the College Board and
he starts doing quite well
and I mean this is what's
really mind-blowing
at age 35 he was able to
transfer to Stanford University
as a computer science student
and that was the Jason,
and by the end of the story
we were all tearing up
this was as powerful,
and then I asked him I was like,
"Hey when everyone leaves
"can I take my phone
out and just video you
"because I think your story,"
obviously it's something
that we love to share
in forums like this
when we're pleading for people to realize
that hey Kahn Academy needs your help
but it's also an inspiring story.
I think we all have days
where we're like,
"Oh things could be a little bit easier
"or I had that setback or that setback."
But when you when you hear a story
like Jason's you realize
that most of our setbacks
are fairly small in comparison
to what he's what he has gone through
and you see how far far he's gone.
And he still has setbacks
but it's amazing how positive he is.
I mean you know when
you have a prison record
it's still hard to get internships
it's still hard to get jobs
even if you have Stanford on your resume.
So I think it's always good,
Thanksgiving was last week,
but I'm still kind of in
the Thanksgiving mode.
I think we all need to really appreciate
how good most of us have it.
And Jason appreciates how good he has it,
even though he's had a tough beginning.
We have more donations.
Rita, thank you Rita,
really appreciate it.
- [Crewman] YouTube's
just joining us live too--
- Oh okay, YouTube--
- [Crewman] YouTube is a
little bit late behind.
We've got our YouTube audience on board.
- All right
- Hi YouTube!
(laughing)
So just explain what's going on here.
Lizzie do you wanna?
- Yeah, yeah.
For sure, so today is Giving Tuesday.
And Khan Academy, we are a non-profit,
so we are asking for your support today,
and we have a goal of raising
$5000 during this livestream,
and during this livestream,
we'll call up people who donate,
and also take your questions.
So if you have any questions,
please put it in the
comments of this livestream.
We'll try to get to as many as we can.
It does look like we have some more.
- And we might also call out
people who aren't donating.
(laughing)
No, we don't know how to do that.
We would do it if we knew how.
But we don't know how.
(laughing)
A few people got scared.
Well thanks Jivan for
donating, means a lot.
People can donate
on Facebook, there's a place to do it,
on YouTube, there's a place,
so that's a new feature they added?
- Yes, yeah.
- So there's a place to donate on YouTube.
- Yeah, it's a blue button
somewhere around the video.
- Someplace.
- [Crewman] Top right.
- [Both] Top right.
- [Crewman] Not of the
screen of the yeah, left.
- Yeah awesome.
- Top right
- And it's on screen
where you can go to donate.
- Okay, you'll figure it out
- Yes, yes.
- And if we raise $5000,
before we show that
I don't want to.
- Oh, oh, yeah.
- It should be motivation enough.
Khan Academy is a not for profit,
it has a mission of free
world class education
for anyone, anywhere.
Your donation will literally help us
serves tens of millions of people.
- Yes, yes.
- And as we explained
to the Facebook users,
we're live streaming on
YouTube and Facebook.
- Yep.
- Simultaneously.
I'm very hi-tech.
- Yeah.
- As we explained, a not for profit
like Khan Academy, no one owns it,
I don't own Khan Academy,
Lizzie doesn't own Khan Academy,
it's a public good, we're
employees of Khan Academy.
But your donations is
what allows us to continue
to provide things for free.
You see a lot of things on the internet
that seem free but they're
making money off of you
in some way, shape or form.
They're feeding you ads
and you don't realize it,
but that's programming your
brain in sometimes shady ways,
maybe they have some kind of freemium,
they're going to try to sell
you something at some point
or they're going to do something--
- With your data.
- Maybe, yeah,
a little bit suspicious with your data,
not always suspicious but
they're going to do something
with your data.
But as a not for profit, and
not only as a not for profit,
we're supported by
philanthropy and our goal
is keep Khan Academy free,
make sure that our bottom
line is not profit,
our bottom line is our mission,
free world class education
for anyone, anywhere.
So hopefully that is
motivation enough to donate
to Khan Academy.
- Yes, yes.
- But just to put some of you
on the edge, over the edge,
not on the edge, over the line,
on top of that if we're
able to raise $5000
over the next half hour, I
will explain this notorious
orders of operations
problem which is fascinating
how popular this has gotten.
But I think most of you all know this.
And also Lizzie and I
are answering questions
and we're also doing shout
outs to people like Adeer
who just gave a donation so thank you
and Victoria Fry, I think,
I don't know if I mentioned Victoria,
well thank you Victoria.
- Wonderful.
So it does look like
we have some questions
that are already coming in.
So what is your advice for
when you can't get your
SAT score up?
- All right, SAT score.
So I think there's a couple of things
so before even thinking about
how to get the SAT score up,
it's just to remind and
we made a video about
de-stressing the SAT.
First appreciate that you
are not your SAT score.
I think especially when
you are in the later stages
of high school and you're in this period
where you're applying to college
and I know that's is happening
to a lot of students right now
or maybe there's a lot of juniors
who are starting to
think about the process
for next year.
It can seem like your whole
identity is going to be defined
by your grades, your extracurriculars,
your SAT score, where you go
to college et cetera et cetera,
everyone's comparing.
And that's not the
healthiest thing in the world
and we've all been there but I think
what you're going to
realize is over the broader
sweep of your life that these are all
just very minor data points.
We have people who've, billionaires,
some of whom who've
donated to Khan Academy
and their SAT scores
were not so impressive,
but they're very impressive people,
they're very entrepreneurial,
they were able to go great things,
and they might've just not
been for whatever reason,
you know, great test takers or
whatever you want to call it.
So that's my first foundational is like
you are not your SAT scores,
you are not your grades,
you are not defined by
where you go to college.
And likewise, I know people
with very good data points
who, you know, for various reasons
have had to struggle in various ways,
so, once again, that's the disclaimer.
- That's a great tip.
- Yes, and it's easy to pretend
that like,
I'm beyond all of this and I
have to remind it to myself
sometimes that sometimes
you visit a friend
with a massive house and you're
like, "Oh, this is nice,"
no, I'm not defined by the
square footage of my house.
But my advice for you for
SAT or really any test,
one, there's direct advice,
we have the official SAT practice,
that we're partnered
with the College Board
and we have many efficacy studies
that have shown that pretty much
every hour that you're able
to engage on the platform,
you are going to grow
and there are better ways
to use things like our
official SAT practice.
I would recommend taking
as many practice tests
as you can.
When you take the practice tests,
try to simulate real testing conditions
as well as possible.
After you've taken the test
and you've graded your test,
look at what you got wrong
and go back to those questions
and make sure that you
understand how they work.
A lot of people when they see a test,
especially like a test like the SAT,
they're just like, "Oh, this is hard,
"there's just going to be
questions I don't know,"
but it's worth appreciating that the SAT,
especially the SAT over
the last several years,
it really doesn't over
anything that isn't taught
outside of algebra two or
outside of the tenth grade.
So if you feel pretty comfortable
and that you shouldn't
look at anything and say,
"Oh this is some type of
"mysterious quantum physics calculus,"
nothing like that's on the SAT,
it's all stuff that you should see
by the time you're in tenth grade.
So you should feel confident
that you can do any problem,
reflect on what you weren't able to do.
Always work on the stuff
that you find maybe most challenging,
sometimes it's a temptation for us
to work on the stuff that's easy.
- Yeah, definitely
- Easy for us.
And what I'm describing
and this would be true
if you are preparing for
some type of a sport as well,
practice what you're not good at,
try to simulate real
conditions when possible,
do that weak point
training and I would say
rather than binge prepare, just
do eight hours all at once,
if you have enough time,
let's says you're a month away
from the SAT, try to
put in 20 minutes a day.
If some days you're able to
put in more that's great.
But if you're able to
do that regular practice
and then maybe once a week
do a full form practice exam,
I think you're going to
be in pretty good shape.
And I've already said this advice,
we were on Instagram, as a pre-livestream.
And I've actually been meditating a ton,
especially the last year and a half,
it's helped me just with
all of the different things
in my life, with family
and work and raising money.
You can sometimes just
get really stressed.
At first when you start meditating
and you start maybe five,
10 minutes at a time,
now I do 30 minutes every morning.
You're like, what am I doing?
Your brain starts like,
you're wasting your time,
you have so much to do.
But slowly your brain starts to still
and when you're in that kind of a mode
everything becomes easier.
And ideally when you take the SAT
you're in that type of a mode,
you've gotten your sleep,
you've got your food
and you're just ready.
And you do what you can and
the chips fall where they do.
One of the things that,
I've been interested in a
lot of Easter philosophy
ever since we did some of
the world history content
on Khan Academy and in Vedic philosophy,
in the Hindu philosophy,
there's these notions
of aspects of the universe
including in work.
And there's sawthwik work
which is work that is true work
that you do because you think it is right
but you're not fixated on the outcome.
Regosic work is work where
you are somewhat fixated
on the outcome.
I'm going to do this because
we're going to raise $5000
and if we don't I'm going
to be really disappointed,
which I will be.
Or if I don't do this I'm
going to get into trouble,
therefore I do it.
And then you have themosic work which is
I'm doing because someone's forcing me
I don't really want to do
it, I'm dragging my feet,
I'm not really into it.
And I think most of us are
kind of in this regosic mode,
most of our lives, we're like,
I need a good SAT score
and if I don't get that
I'm going to be miserable
and I'm going to suffer.
And as Buddha says, "Suffering
is all caused by attachment,"
especially attachment to outcome.
So I remind myself every day
and it definitely de-stresses me
and anyone preparing for a
test or anything in life,
try to take that sathwik attitude.
Definitely put work into
it, put energy in it,
do what you think is right
but don't be obsessed
with the outcome, the
outcome is what it is.
If you do what you think is right
the chips fall where
they do and then not only
will you find yourself less stressed,
but you'll probably have
better outcomes as well
when you're not obsessed with them.
It's a long answer, I got
a little bit more preachy
than I.
- Yeah but super helpful and
great things to think about
even like passing SATs.
- You're very flattering
Lizzie, yes, yes.
- Even just regularly--
- No, what I just said
applies well beyond the SATs
and I still work.
Let's see other people.
Monica Kahn, maybe we're related,
thank you for your donation.
Rocky Kirk, thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- Suyog Chandramouli, thank you
and twee dam, thank you so much
for your donations.
Let's see.
- All right
there was a funny comment,
so when I hear Sal's
voice I want to do math.
- That's great, go do math.
- Yes, that's awesome.
Another question from YouTube,
how did you get the idea
to start Khan Academy?
- Well I'll tell the story,
I'll give the short version
of it.
From a very early age I was
actually very fascinated
by education even in undergrad
when I was a CS major, a math major,
I was always fascinated by
how computers could be used
to maybe help teach people
and I had some projects there.
But I ended up working in tech,
I ended up working
eventually at a hedge fund,
which is really just a fancy
word for an investment firm
that has more flexibility.
And while I was doing that,
right after my wedding,
my 12 year old cousin, Nadia,
it just came out in conversation
that she was having trouble in math,
so I offered to tutor her remotely,
I was in Boston, she was in New Orleans.
So I start working with her,
it was actually unit conversion
she was having trouble with.
She got through that, she
got caught up with her class,
a little ahead of her class.
At that point she became
what I call a tiger cousin
and I called up her school and I said,
"I think Nadia should
retake that placement test."
And they said, "Who are you?"
And I said, "I'm her cousin."
And they let her and
then she was actually put
into an advanced math class
so I was a little bit hooked,
this was 15 years ago.
And then I started tutoring
her younger brothers
and word spreads around my
family that free tutoring
is going on so I wax
tutoring like 10, 15 cousins.
And then I thought, hey
these are great guinea pigs
for me test some of my ideas out on
like software and so I
wrote some software for them
from that practice problems.
'Cause I saw all them, their main issue
is they had gaps, a lot of them
they were trying their best,
and they were all A or B students,
but the reason why they're
having trouble in algebra
wasn't that algebra was difficult,
it wasn't that why weren't bright,
it's that they might've
been a little bit shaky
on negative numbers or a little shaky
on dividing decimals from 5th grade.
And so I was their tutor
to fill in those gaps
but also I wanted to give them practice
so that they could get that feedback.
And that was the first Khan Academy,
I had to put it on a website some place
and the Khan Academy
domain name was available.
I looked at stuff like Math Planet.
But it was kind of
almost just a funny thing
'cause it was just like me and my cousins.
And I kind of dreamt that
maybe one day other people
could use this stuff and
it was actually a friend,
it had nothing to do
with videos initially,
and a friend said, "How are
you scaling your lessons?"
And I said, "I'm not, it's hard to do,"
at that point I had 15 cousins
that I was able to do with Nadia
and he says, "Why don't
you make some videos
"and upload them onto
YouTube for your family?"
And I immediately thought
that was a horrible idea,
I said, "YouTube's for cats playing piano,
'not serious math,"
many people have heard me say that,
but that was the actual interchange.
It was either that or dogs on skateboards,
but you get the idea.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I got over the idea
that it wasn't my idea
which is an important thing in life.
And I gave it a shot
and those YouTube videos
started to get watched by
people who weren't my family
and one thing led to another and by 2010,
2009, I had trouble focusing on my day job
because there was about 100
000 people who were using
this thing called Khan Academy.
And so 2008 I had set it
up as a not for profit
and actually at the time I was hoping,
if I could really well
in the investment world
maybe one day in 10 years, 20 years,
I would have enough money
to be able to retire
and do this,
but then events happened
faster than I expected
and I didn't have anywhere
near enough money.
I was saving up money for
a down payment on our house
and our first child had been born
but you know, the zeitgeist of the world,
something was making me do this.
But yeah, and quit my job,
took a while to get some
of that first funding
and then we're still raising money
that's why we're here
trying to raise $5000.
I will do this order of
operations problem for you.
And you can explain this to family members
and impress co-workers
and people you meet in social gatherings.
- Yeah like good holiday conversations.
- Yeah I think if you walk up to someone
that you might find appealing
at a party or something.
I mean I think, what's cooler than that?
You might think order
of operations is boring
but let me tell you.
(both laughing
But anyway, that's how Khan Academy,
that's how, and that
was back in 2009, 2010
and we've just been on
a ride together since.
And to be clear, Khan Academy
is much more than me now,
you see some great people in this room
and then there's 200
people outside of this room
who help forward Khan Academy's mission,
your donations helps us
have a team that can do this
and there's actually
thousands of volunteers
on top of that.
- Like engineers and content creators,
marketers, fund raisers.
- Yeah, educators, teachers,
we have a thousand.
With your donation, just so people know,
we have to spend many millions of dollars
just to keep the servers
going on Khan Academy.
So it's a real operation.
But in the course of the next few minutes
if we can raise $5000.
- Yeah that would be awesome.
- Order of operations.
- And then we'll do
some math problems.
- Order of operations problems.
- Awesome.
So we have some more
questions that came in.
- And we have donations too.
- You want to talk about those?
- Ang Lee thank you very much, Ang.
And Heather Di Diego, thank you so much,
donated on YouTube, she
found the blue button.
- That's awesome, awesome.
Cool, so what is your favorite subject?
- My favorite subject.
You know, it's changed over time
and it's really, it's
kind of whatever I'm into
at the moment.
I would say when I was growing up,
my favorite subjects
were probably people wouldn't be surprised
to hear math and science
but also I was really into art growing up,
so those are my favorite subjects.
I actually thought I was
going to be a cartoonist
when I was, so obviously with the videos
I found an outlet to sketch for people.
But now, through Khan Academy
we've worked on many subjects
and I think the key is realizing
that almost every subject
is actually really really
really interesting.
Someone on, I think it was
on Instagram had just asked,
how do I get the motivation to study?
And for me it's, 'cause I have
to study for Khan Academy,
in fact, I'm one of the few
people over the age of 40
who has to study the same
things that many of y'all
have to study to make sure that I.
But I don't want to study to just like
be able to go through the motions
or just to be able to get an answer right.
I want to study to be able to appreciate
the mystery of the universe.
And what you've got to
realize is a lot of the stuff
that you might see in a textbook
or that you might see on Khan Academy
or other places,
you might view it as,
"I've gotta figure out
"how this equation works,
or I've got to figure out
"what entropy means," or this or that.
But you should be excited
because for example,
notions of entropy,
these are things that people have pondered
for hundreds of thousands of years
and some people dedicated
their entire careers
to some aspect of it
and you're able to open up a
textbook or click on a video
and essentially get the answer.
And in some ways it spoils it
that you didn't struggle with it that long
but you should get excited in that way.
Think about how someone, Issac Newton
would've given anything to get his hands
on all of your textbooks.
- Right.
- Anyone, even a hundred years ago
would give their arm to get
their hands on your textbooks,
Khan Academy, et cetera, et cetera,
because there's just so
much knowledge in it.
So when you have that mindset
any subject becomes really
really really interesting
and for me I love to look at subjects
and start to realize connections
that I had never seen before.
So I've actually recently
really gotten into etymology,
because when you look at
where words comes from
it starts to actually even explain a lot.
One of my favorite ones,
if this doesn't impress
people at social gatherings
what I'm about to tell you will.
I was talking about Eastern
philosophy and the Vedas,
the Vedas are 3500 or older year old texts
that are the basis of
Hinduism and Hindu philosophy.
And in the Veda, the most
mentioned god is Indra,
who is kind of the sky god
and he has aspects of Thor
in Nordic mythology.
And Indra's father's mentioned
in the Vedas 10 times
as sky father and sky father
is Dyeus Pather in Sanskrit.
Dyeus Pather, Jupiter, Zeus Pater,
so Jupiter, Zeus Pater and Dyeus Pather
are all essentially and this
was one of the first pieces
of evidence when the British came to India
and they got some of the
Hindu priests to say,
"Hey, teach us Sanskrit."
That was the first time
that they realized all these connections
between all of these languages.
It actually wasn't as obvious
that even the Germanic languages
and the Latin based languages
were so closely connected.
When they saw Sanskrit in
India is so closely tied
to these languages, it in
some ways blew everyone's mind
and they started realizing
wow, there must've been a people,
a lot of Western historians would say,
people who originated in central
Asian out of the Caucasus.
A lot of Indians would say
maybe out of even North India,
but you share this common ancestry.
Things like that, at least for me,
give me chills
because you're like
wow, there's like this,
just over the last three,
four thousand years
the things that have happened.
And humanity, modern humans have been,
physiologically modern humans
have been around for several
hundreds of thousands of years,
so just to even think about
all the things we don't know,
all the stories.
That kind of stuff gives me chills.
So that's the kind of
thing when I was a kid,
I was always interested by epic stories
but sometimes if I was sitting
in my 7th grade history
class, I wasn't as interested.
But when I started to
view history like this
then it all became super interesting
so long answer to my favorite subject
- That's incredible.
So we have some more
donations that have come in,
thank you so much.
- Yes, thank you Margaret,
really appreciate the donation.
Mohammed, thank you for your donation.
And you're Mohammed Ruman,
my mother's maiden name is Ruman,
so maybe we're related, thank you.
We're all related as we just talked about,
we're all related.
It's actually a fun game, if once again,
if you can't impress people with this,
to just think about how
far you have to go back
to have a common ancestor.
And obviously, maybe,
23andMe, and stuff can answer
these questions,
but it's fun to just think about,
well maybe someone in
Genghis Kahn's army. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- Thank you, thank you
Russel for your donation.
Thank you Katerina for your donation.
Thank you Daniel for your donation.
- Thanks so much.
- It makes a huge difference
and it means a lot.
And look, it both helps
us fuel what we do,
but hopefully as you donate,
you feel like you are part of our--
- Exactly.
- Team and our adventure and our mission
and you become an ambassador
for what we do as well.
Because it's not going to happen,
we have a lot of people
here who are gung ho
about what we need to do
but obviously something
like free world class
education for anyone, anywhere
is a very very big statement.
- Yeah and it takes all of us.
- It takes all of us
and we're going to need a lot of partners
and hopefully you also view
yourself as part of that army,
that movement that can
help the world get there.
So thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- Just a reminder we're
trying to raise $5000.
- Yes, yes, during this livestream.
And you can donate on YouTube, on Facebook
or you can go to our website
at khanacademy.org/donate.
- I like that question, what
is my least favorite subject?
- Yeah, that is a good one.
- Celebrity gossip.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- And I say that because
sometimes I too get drawn in.
I know what you're thinking Sal, no,
you're always studying
Sanskrit and high minded,
there's no way you're drawn to click bait,
but yes, I too.
But I don't feel good after
I've read some of those things.
So it's my least favorite subject.
I don't know what's your
least favorite subject?
- I think my least favorite
subject would probably
be math because I never
felt like I was good
at math but I didn't have Khan
Academy when I was growing up
so I didn't.
- Lizzie is well, you are
here and you should be getting
on that.
- I know, I know, I need to,
I have started a little bit
I have been working through
some algebra.
- Good, good.
You know actually one of the people
who almost was one of
the people who helped me,
who convinced me to quit my job to work on
Khan Academy.
He said, and this was a man
who had actually started
a bunch of restaurants, he's a
very successful restaurateur.
And he said, his name
is Jeremiah Hennessy,
he's the founder of BJ's restaurants.
And he just randomly
started calling me in 2008
saying you need to quit your job
'cause Khan Academy is too, you know,
I was like, "Really who are you?"
And he's like, "I own BJ's
restaurants I've been there,
good casual dining.
But he was telling me that
he, when he hires people
he divides the world between
people who know algebra
and don't know algebra.
Not that like a restaurant
manager is going to have to solve
simultaneous equations
and things like that
but algebra builds those
critical thinking skills
and that meta-cognition
that you feel confident
that they can learn higher order things.
So I actually do think that if everyone,
almost everyone has taken algebra,
at least in places like the US,
but if everyone really mastered algebra,
I actually think our level
of discourse would go up.
It's not like algebra is
the end all and be all
but it's one of many things
that if people got there,
critical thinking and public
discourse would go up,
people would feel more confident engaging,
they wouldn't just defer to
experts and things like that.
So learn your algebra.
- Yes, yes, I'm trying.
All right so some other questions.
So what your plans for creating content
in other languages?
- So we have 40 translation
and localisation projects
going on at Khan Academy around the world
and these are done by
incredible volunteers.
Some of them have local sponsorship,
some of them are just very
similar to what I was doing
10 years ago, in their equivalent
of their walk-in closets
just trying to make it work,
trying to be of service
to the people in their geographies.
We have more formal
projects in Latin America,
we have a partnership with the
Lemon Foundation in Brazil,
the Slim Foundation in Mexico,
Carlos Rodriguez-Pastor in Peru,
have been incredible supporters
and we have teams in those places
that are doing localisation
not just of the videos but the exercises.
They're creating some new content,
they're aligning it to
the various standards
in those areas.
We also have a fairly decent sized team,
14 people in India.
- Wow.
- We just had a presentation
from them yesterday,
where they are not only
localizing the content,
making that new content.
India's interesting 'cause
there's many languages
in India but making it work
for the various languages
and various standards, so
that's our plans right now,
that's what we're currently doing.
But obviously over the long arc,
we want to be able to reach
everyone on the planet.
- Yeah, that's our mission.
All right so we have some other ones here.
What do you think are the main hurdles
for Khan Academy to achieve its mission?
- The main hurdles for Khan
Academy to achieve its mission.
So I mean it might sound
a little bit too obvious
at a fundraising livestream.
- Right, right, yes, money.
- But yes, it takes resources
and as I said before,
you know, our mission,
governments are spending
trillions of dollars
trying to essentially
tackle the same mission,
and a lot is good coming out of it
but Khan Academy is the
budget of a large high school.
And we reach on the order of
a 100 million people every year.
But to do that it takes resources.
So the first thing is, I
probably spend 40% of my time
fundraising because if we
don't have those resources
we're not going to able to do
everything we've talked about
so I think that's number one.
I think after that the main thing is,
and I think we've been
making good progress on this
so I don't think it's
going to be a barrier
but I think we have to keep pushing,
is finding ways that we
can work more formally
with major school districts,
that's something we're doing right now,
we have a partnership with
Los Vegas, Clarke County,
where students are using it as part of,
they take this assessment called
the Math Growth Assessment
and now that assessment acts
as a diagnostic and placement
for Khan Academy.
And then the students
are able to work on that
and the district's able
to see how Khan Academy
is able to, not only how the map
can help influence personalized
plans on Khan Academy,
but they can understand how
Khan Academy is hopefully
growing the students more than expected.
So I think we need to do
more things like that.
I think we need to be able to,
there's a lot of stuff, our
team has a huge list of stuff
we want to improve on the
experience on Khan Academy.
I got out of a meeting
earlier this morning
where we're talking about
improving our math content
even more, adding new content areas,
we want to improve the game mechanics,
make it even more motivating
to use Khan Academy.
We're constantly trying
to study the efficacy
of what we're doing, all
of that takes resources.
Yeah and then I think we
just have to keep doing that,
add more subjects.
There's some longer, big picture things
that I would want to eventually tackle
like how does the learning on Khan Academy
translate into opportunity?
Whether that's some form of credential
or connections to internships
or jobs or higher education,
I think that's something
that we need to figure out.
I'd like to get started on that
within the next five years.
But, yeah, those are our big things,
but the resources.
Let me put it this way,
our ideas right now
are bigger than our capacity.
So if we could raise
$5000 that will move us
in that direction
and I'll also do the order
of operations problem,
I don't know if anyone
really wants me to do it,
but I'll do it.
- Yeah, that would be great, yes.
We did just receive some more donations.
- All right.
And Micheal or Michelle, Michelle?
Amorikan, thank you so much.
Daniel.
- Yeah thank you so much.
- Thank you so much for the donation.
- Awesome.
So we have a few minutes left
we're actually going to move to
what we call the lighting round
so we're going to do 10 questions
and you have 10 seconds to answer each.
- Okay.
- To each question or all.
- [Crew Member] Each question.
- Now that would be ridiculous.
- That would be really really hard.
Okay cool, awesome.
- Oh, we're being timed?
- So tell me when to start.
Okay, cool.
So what's your favorite color?
- Blue.
- Do you have a black hole badge?
- I have two.
- Ooh.
- Because it's nepotism, I don't know.
Not nepotism but it's misuse of power.
- What is your favorite exercise?
Physical exercise?
- Dead lifts.
- Okay.
Who is your favorite
inventor or scientist?
- Favorite inventor or scientist.
I will just go with Leonardo Di Vinci.
- Awesome, mine too.
- If you were a classroom teacher,
what grade would you want to teach?
- Oh, oh.
I would want to teach, I'm gonna cheat,
I would teach a mixed age classroom
and I would make the older
kids teach the younger kids
and I would be kind of
the Dumbledore of it all.
- Nice, well is that it?
All right, well we can go
through a couple more of these.
So what's your favorite food?
- Favorite, dark chocolate.
- Awesome
Favorite chemical element.
- Favorite, oxygen.
- Awesome.
What Hogwarts house do you belong to?
- Oh.
Oh, I would like to believe it's a toss up
between Gryffindor, I will
just go with Gryffindor,
it's a cop out.
- What's your favorite TV show?
- Oh, favorite TV show.
I've been enjoying, I've been enjoying,
well there's several.
I enjoy "The Good Place."
- Okay, yeah that's a good one.
- That's a good one.
- I like to actually, I've
been watching with my kids,
"Where In The World Is
Carmen Sandiego" on Netflix.
- Oh nice.
- It's quite good.
- Oh, awesome.
- Quite, like I can't
wait for season three.
- That's awesome.
I haven't watched it yet.
And then the last one,
"Star Trek" or "Star Wars"?
- You know, I think before
some of newer ones came out
I would've said "Star Wars"
but now maybe "Star Trek",
'cause I think they keep
repeating the same plot line.
The Empire has this weapon
that can destroy a planet.
Anyway, I'm happy to
help them if they want.
- One more donation.
- Oh Derrick, thank you so much.
- Oh and another one.
- [Crewman] Marci wants to join.
- Dan, thank you so much.
- Yeah, thanks Dan.
- Oh, Marci's here too,
Marci you want to come up here?
You want to come up?
- You want to come here?
- Come on, come on, come here.
- Come here, come here.
- Come here.
- Come up here, come up here.
- Can you come up here?
Come, up.
- Can you sit up here?
- Oh, yeah, there you go, oh yeah.
Marci, did we get to our target?
Do we know?
Shall I explain the order
of operations regardless?
- Yeah, let's do that.
- All right, because, all right.
So the reason, y'all
have seen this before.
The reason why this I think went viral
is some people, you know
you learn in school,
order of operations, some
people learn things like PEMDAS,
which is like
parentheses, exponents,
multiplication, division,
addition, subtraction.
You often times learned in school,
you do parenthesis first, that's obvious,
but then multiplication and
division are kind of equal
and when in doubt you
do them left to right
and then addition and
subtraction are kind of equal
and when in doubt do them left to right.
What's tricky here is,
okay so the obvious part
is to do the parenthesis first,
I don't think anyone debates that.
So that's just four right there.
So you have eight divided
by two times four.
Now if you take the left
to right attitude about it,
you'd say eight divided
by two is four times four
which is 16, that's one
way people have done it.
The other way people have said is,
"Wait, but if I see a number
right next to the parenthesis,
"I feel like I have to
multiply that first."
- Right.
- So people say two
times four that's eight,
and then eight divided
by eight would be one,
so you get either 16 or one.
I think, maybe other
people got other things
but that might a little
bit more suspicious.
My take on it, I mean one,
this tells you why you learn
something like order of operations.
Order of operations are just
to try to remove ambiguity
from mathematical expressions like this.
My view on this is.
If I see a number right
next to parenthesis,
I almost view that as like
a light form of parenthesis,
a light form of emphasis of like,
you're going to do that,
you're going to do that first.
So I would, my inclination
would be to go to the one.
Eight divided by two times
four, so eight divided eight
which is one.
But, this is why if you're doing it,
look, even if you're doing a maths thesis,
this is why it's good to
even use more parenthesis,
when in doubt use extra parenthesis,
if you think what you're
saying can be ambiguous.
In fact, that's not true just in math,
that's true in life especially
if it's something important,
explain it, be very clear.
But you know, these are just symbols
that are trying to convey an idea
and you don't want to be ambiguous
and so if you think it's
going to be ambiguous
just put another parenthesis around that.
Or if you really wanted
the eight to be divided
by two before you multiply,
then put the parenthesis
around that first.
So I would say whoever
did this just should've
included more parenthesis,
but my inclination
is definitely to do the two
times the parenthesis first
'cause it's right next to it.
If there's a multiplication symbol there
then I probably would've
gone left to right,
hopefully that's helpful.
- Yeah, yeah, awesome.
Cool, well we have another donation.
- Marci left.
- Yeah.
- Wasn't really interested
in my explanation.
- Awesome.
- Oh Corey.
- Thank you so much Corey,
- Corey, thank you
- for your donation, awesome.
So it looks like we've raised
about a thousand so far
on YouTube and 830 on Facebook
which is super exciting,
thank you all for your donations.
- Thank you, thank you so much everyone.
- Yeah, for sure.
So like we were talking about earlier,
today is Giving Tuesday
and we are a non-profit
so any support is super helpful
and a dollar does provide
three hours of learning time
so you could have a huge
impact with your gift
and you can always give
at khanacademy.org/donate.
But yeah, I think we're
out of time for today.
Awesome, do you have any last
things you'd like to say?
- No, well you know,
thank you for viewing.
You know it means a lot that
y'all are part of this journey
with us.
It's a big audacious mission.
I tell the team here all the time
that you know, there was a time
where it was just me in a walk-in closet,
that's the first chapter of Khan Academy.
Then around 2009, 2010,
we were able to get
some of the first
support to start building
this incredible team.
Here's some management advice, hire up,
you can't go wrong that way
and I think Khan Academy's
now entering a phase
where we reach tens of
millions of students
but we want to be able to
reach hundreds of millions
and reach them in a really
deep and substantive way
so that story of Jason, that
young man who was in prison
for 15 years, we have people
in places like Afghanistan,
young girls who the Taliban
forbade from going to school,
who are able to learn on Khan Academy
and now they're doing physics research.
We want to multiply those
stories by a thousand fold
or a million fold.
I hope that everyone, all
of us and everyone watching
that are our kids or our
grandchildren can't imagine a world
where free world class
education for anyone, anywhere
isn't essentially a human right.
So thank you for helping us
move towards that vision,
thank you.
- Thank you so much, have a great day.